neuf équipes jeunes du super g un chef
de bande de bande dessinée mais chut
notre belge leurs auteurs ap midam font
le bonheur des coudes avec c'est leur 4e
match ont laissé faire et des enfants
qui le connaissent par coeur qui bat del
et préfèrent les jeux vidéo alors que
titeuf non méthylé faire reconnaître les
gammes dans une playstation et du box
pour cette bd si quand même parce que
pour inventer sa foi quand même
s'inspirer jeu vidéo
or maniacs un certain barbarians presse
c'est quelque chose pour moi j'aime pas
du tout ça mais bon c'était un travail
de commande et je me suis dit pompe est
une chance à prendre
et comme j'avais envie de raconter des
histoires je me suis dit mais pourquoi
pas on va essayer avec ça quitte fadul
est née en 1996 dans le journal spirou
une page pour illustrer la rubrique des
jeux vidéo avant de devenir un album en
dix volumes cette bd s'est vendu à deux
millions et demi des dons
numéro dark vador s'est tout de suite
trouvé en tchèque des bons au niveau
toutes catégories confondues je suis pas
surpris parce que j'y ai mis tout
absolument tout ce que je pouvais pour
que ça fasse à succès pas encore de quoi
faire trembler titoff ford evos 13
millions d'albums vendus s'occupe 1992
up concurrence dans la bande dessinée
chacun chat son truc
et puis je pense pas que ça c'est pas de
la politique
vous n'allez pas adhérer à un personnage
plutôt calme alors les bagarres ne
serait-elle que sur le papier dans le
monde 2008 sont là
les dpj surtout avec les folies de vie
mais il doit savoir 2 millions d'euros
soit 6 heures